hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Dan cyber
we're gonna watch the trailer today for
a highly anticipated videogame mm-hmm
called no man's sky and you look excited
I'm so [ __ ] shave your pants right
now it is crazy
oh you did actually mm-hmm I make sure
that I put things in my system that come
clean okay yeah I drink sparkly yeah I
drink bleach oh okay it's a secret
bleach yeah I'm gonna try it at home
kids I'm gonna start taking bleaching
because it's a good sense so I'm not
gonna flush when I go to the bathroom
now yeah this game got a lot of great
feedback at the e3 convention like a lot
of critics for Haley it is like the best
new game so yeah I'm pretty stoked to
see it it's I hear they have space
battles in them mm-hmm that sounds
[ __ ] cool like a good space battle
yeah uncharted territory yeah no I'm
pretty stoked to see ya
Wow
Wow looks oh damn oh sweet Dave looks
like a difference a bunch of different
styles yeah
space battles
it's just insane what
this sort of power in Italy now how do
they expect you don't that was cool
ps4 game right ps4 and I believe PC Xbox
I don't know if it is let us know in the
comments down below yeah please do you
don't have to want to murder us just
because we got it a little wrong cuz I
mess up a lot this guy doesn't know [ __ ]
it's made a mistake know that game does
like awesome looks like an experience
you know like one of the one of those
rare games that's like oh I'd love to
play that game stoned oh you would be
tripping really bad Ryan Ryan you got a
move Ryan right right okay we lost Brian
[ __ ] oh yeah that game does like [ __ ]
awesome is this the space battles look
like it looks like a combination of like
a lot of different gameplay it is it
like it incorporates a lot in there and
one of the coolest parts of Bobbie is
that every time a new person joins one
of the servers uh-huh that person is put
on their very own planet oh wow so yeah
you get a server of a thousand people
that's a thousand different planets Wow
[ __ ] okay yeah it's pretty [ __ ] cool
yeah it's super ambitious and I'm really
it looks like it's gonna pull through
and give us something [ __ ] awesome
and I just I hope ya frame that this is
gonna be like the next huge like the
next Minecraft like everyone plays
minecraft all the time I was playing
this weekend nice I'm usin minecraft
yeah and this I'm hoping has that same
sort of feel it's just gonna be a matter
of how it you know perceives to move
everything so I'm sure it'll deliver
like the reception is like
overwhelmingly positive
yeah so I'm sure it's gonna yeah and if
the guys developing this game I think
the like just graduated from college
oh really yeah they're super young dev T
you hate those [ __ ] VA people like
that who are just like hey I'm still
young and I'm super successful now yeah
not like I want well thanks guys for
telling us about the trailer me now if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe here for the real rejects if
you want check up down scammy channel
right here right here quick right here
right here for that cyber channel for
some video games we played some slender
anxiety it was amazing here it was a
damn good time I scared my pants murder
that slender hmm you weren't wearing
pants no I wasn't wearing pants so
that's something I look forward to let's
do some shout outs damn [ __ ] oh all
right that sounds like a stupendous idea
Perry Smith yo okay so I'm a little
confused here Perry you said you want to
shout out you said please which was
awesome but your name's Perry is Perry
also a girl's name because he has a
picture of some broad I think that I'm
bringing back the word broad I think she
did that I think she's the broad you're
the broad I think so you think so I
think so
well what's up Perry are you doing a
girl what's going on I just come over
sometime on my channel
seems don't worry come on over yes do
you live in California comment below and
let me know that's what Jeremy John says
really comment below let me know
yes clever that's why he has 500,000
subscribers damn
yeah Perry you look beautiful in your
thumbnail hmm so let me show you a
beautiful time I'll be around he keeps
me as a butler on weekends I like people
to watch uh what I like people to watch
I want you to I want you to watch then
no Perry and I are gonna do some crazy
things in there right Harry
can I can I not know well I need someone
to record the camera I don't want a
[ __ ] tripod or something what
I wanted to be like moving around in
some real cinematic shots come I knew
when I moved to California I was gonna
get into porn while [ __ ] my mother's
gonna be so proud yeah your mom will be
proud creative motion films he said hey
Ryan I thought your videos were really
cool and inspired me to do what I like
no matter what dude thanks and I was
wondering if I can get a shot of course
you can get a shout-out mmm
dude you just complimented my heart
Perry you complimented my dick create
emotions pictures you complimented my
heart thank you thank you made me feel
very flattered and his ego groves once
again I don't I don't know what this ego
is you're talking about ego you don't
never heard the word before
yeah I mean let's just face it
I am the [ __ ] so for you to say that is
just it's pretty obvious it's pretty
[ __ ] obvious I'm a little too cool
for school you know what I mean
I roll the bowl whatever that means
you rule the bowl yeah well then I think
it's time for us to go to Spain and run
with the Bulls knows apparently your
rule then I had a run every Bowl I'm
really fast really fast you just see me
on the streets okay fast yeah actually
yes I have you're surprisingly fast
yeah any creative motion pictures thank
you spade prep mouse if you have a big
dick Ryan give me a shout-out I can't
give this guys
well I could give you one go for it
shoutout now he's gonna send his secret
assassins to cut off my dick he's gonna
feed it to his dogs PS he loves my
videos when he loves your videos and
yeah hey it's not all bad
not all dad man it's like I want to give
a guy a shout-out but he had this one
condition and unfortunately can't live
up to
I mean it's thick at least that's what
some guys have said some guys yeah a
long story craigslist whole thing it was
i was experimenting and first guy you
know like there's a little uncomfortable
second guy was i had a zit a pair on my
dick and so he stopped blowing me third
guy lasted a long time but i just wasn't
into it I realized the cold guy thing
isn't for me you know but yeah they all
said I had thick dicks wait no not
multiple dick else that I had a thick
dick because I'm speeding just like
speed ah Perry come over